in brussels bleak weather to match the
angry mood
the dispute over vaccines is not blowing
over and today europe announced plans
for a transparency mechanism
that's a handy euphemism for having more
control
over authorizing exports of vaccine
and that means a ban on vaccines moving
freely between the republic of ireland
and northern ireland
raising the specter of border controls
less than a month
after brexit talks came to an end
officials here deny it's a precursor to
blocking vaccine exports
but it is clearly a warning challenges
we now face
left us with no other choice but to act
the aim is to provide us immediately
with
full transparency uh transparency that
until now has been lacking and what
europeans expect
and if needed it also will provide us
with a tool
to ensure vaccine deliveries
the commission has adopted a strictly
targeted measure
that will allow us to gather accurate
information about the production of
vaccines
and where manufacturers intend to ship
them
and now the pressure is more intense the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine has been
authorized for use
around europe we now have three vaccines
that have been developed and recommended
for provi approval
against a disease that we did not know
one year ago none of them is perfect
none of them is a magic wand on its own
but together
they provide tools and options to
prevent different aspects of the disease
the question is how many doses of this
vaccine europe will now get
the number it ordered or the number that
astrazeneca says it can supply
the company adamant it's acted in good
faith
we have millions of doses that we are
ready to start uh
shipping to the to the eu over the next
few days and
and and weeks so so you know we have
quite a quite a substantial quantity
already to ship to the various countries
and we're working 24 7 to increase
this capacity and at the heart of this
rancorous row
is this the 41-page contract between
astrazeneca
and the european commission now in this
there are details about uk
factories involved in the european
supply line
but there are also bits that are very
vaguely worded the truth is both sides
will use
this document to support their own
argument so will it resolve the row
no chance europe's vaccine rollout has
generally been
far more sluggish than the uk and for
all its political clout brussels is no
exception
we have the delays and it's really not
going fast enough
i can't say that i feel proud with a
european response
i think of course they are enforcing
situations and that maybe they are not
going as fast as they would like to
but they are trying to do their best
vaccines have become
a precious and political commodity with
the power to save lives
and clearly the potential to cause very
profound
arguments adam parsons sky news brussels